- [Instructor] There are
461 homes in the part
of town where Samir lives.
He counted that 352 of
those homes are apartments.
How many of the homes are not apartments?
So like always, pause this video and see
if you can work through it on your own.
All right, now let's do this together.
So we're starting with 461 homes.
So we have 461, and we wanna know how many
are not apartments.
So what we wanna do is take out the number
that are apartments.
And they tell us that 352 of
those homes are apartments.
So we'll take out the
number that are apartments
and what we will left it with is going
to be the number that are not apartments.
So we really just have to
evaluate 461 minus 352.
And as we've talked about in other videos
there's many techniques for doing this.
We could break apart 352 into
the various place values.
So we could say that
this is the same thing
as 461 minus, we'll do
this in different colors,
minus three hundreds,
or 300, minus five tens,
or 50, and then minus
two, and then minus two
right over there.
And then you might be able to figure out
that 461 minus 300, that
that is going to be,
I'm just taking three 100s from this,
so that's going to be 161.
And then if I subtract 50 from that, well,
what's 61 minus 50?
Well, that would be 11.
So 161 minus 50 would be 111.
Or another way of thinking about it
is if you take these five 10s away
from these six 10s, you'll
be left with one 10,
so that would be 100, one 10, and one one.
So you have 111.
And then you want to subtract that two,
last but not least, and 11
minus two would be nine.
So 111 minus two would be equal to 109.
But I mentioned there's many other ways
that you might try to
approach something like this.
You could say, hey, well maybe it's easier
to subtract 50, or 350
I should say, then 352
and so you could subtract two
from both of these numbers.
So if you subtract two
from 461, if you subtract
one you get to 460, you
subtract two you get to 459.
459 minus, you subtract two
from this you get to 350.
And this is all about the idea
that the difference doesn't change as long
as you add or subtract
the same number to both.
And so here we might say that four 100s
minus three 100s is 100.
And then 59 minus 50 is nine.
So we would get the same result.
The thing to appreciate
is that this is all
about subtracting 352
from 461 and that there's
multiple ways of calculating this.